[Music]
so let me ask you a question about a
comment that you made in
the
brotherhood of the screaming abyss about
lsd is a potential treatment for
dyslexia now i don't have all the
context but i pulled this out
and
this is a is going to lead to a broader
question about
perhaps unusual or unexpected
applications
or indications for psychedelics but this
this section here reads it did leave me
to speculate about the use of lsd as a
potential treatment for dyslexia we have
a limited understanding of
neuroplasticity to say nothing of how
psychedelics might affect it that man's
anecdote so of course i've omitted an
anecdote hints at the curious link
between psychedelics and language as do
the more prevalent accounts of
synesthesia i've discussed earlier
and then i'll actually read one more
sense psychedelics have some fundamental
relationship to the way our brains
create meaning and understanding out of
sounds and images
i'm convinced that further
investigations into this phenomenon
would yield new insights
could you could you expand on that
because i would agree certainly with the
uh the assertion of this fundamental
relationship
any thoughts on lsd specifically is
perhaps a
a tool for addressing dyslexia or or
psychedelics for any other indications
that people might not guess
the connection to
lsd and language and i think even more
so with mushrooms because
you're probably familiar with an essay
i think by henry munn
that was published in a book called uh
i think it was by peter first called
hallucinogens and culture this was
around 1970. there's a wonderful chapter
in there called the mushrooms of
language it's by henry munn
and it makes the point and again like i
talk about this in the brotherhood of
the screaming abyss you it makes the
point that in this be mushroom state
the poetry the language becomes much
more fluid it just sort of flows out of
you and that's why
these people can chant for
hours and and they're actually
instantiating
you know their the mushroom is speaking
through them
this gnosis literally this the logos is
the word the true
the pure logos actually flows through
them and then there's the phenomenon of
synesthesia
which psychedelics especially mushrooms
can reliably do and you know i've the
association with meaningful images with
sound
some people are naturally genetically
synesthetic
and it's very often it's very
interesting how their
synthetic experiences
often have to do with words and numbers
and things like that and they'll say
things like well
the number 13 is chrome shaped and spiky
you know shiny and spiky what
but for them that's a reality
and i think you know i've argued that uh
mushrooms well i have tariffs have lots
of people have that mushrooms were
important in the origin of consciousness
so i think that
it is
this
this connection to language that
consciousness
depends
what we understand as true consciousness
depends on this
construction of this world view
essentially and that's built on language
this artificial reality that we
construct first for ourselves that's a
combination of
sensory input
that is filtered and processed in a
certain way and
linked to associations memories
all of that kind of thing so we build
this
you know what the neuroscientists now
call the default mode network which is
kind of ordinary state of consciousness
long before i heard of the default mode
network i was calling it the reality
hallucination
effectively we live in a hallucination
we live in an artificial world reality
that our brains construct
and it must reflect
whatever is out there
because we're not wandering around
stepping in front of buses and things
like that so it does map to reality in
some ways but it's a it's actually an
impoverished version of reality what the
a lot of what the brain does
is filter things out you know and huxley
had this insight he talked about the
reducing valve
that to make the world comprehensible
you have to selectively filter
what gets in
and uh
your you inhabit this
filtered
you could almost use the word curated
version of reality
otherwise it would just be a blooming
buzzing confusion
and you wouldn't you wouldn't be able to
navigate
and then you can take a psychedelic you
can disable those mechanisms you can you
can disable this default mode
mechanism
open the gates of the reducing valve
and
that can be very beneficial
in terms of helping you get outside of
your reference frame
and that's very useful i think that
that's what psychedelics i think that's
where the therapeutic effect really
for many of the things it's indicated
for it's this ability to step outside
your reference frame temporarily
and look at your situation from a
different perspective
and but you wouldn't want to be there
all the time right because you wouldn't
be functional that's again why you have
to be very selective about your sentence
setting when you do these things it's a
complex topic because i think it does
relate to the way
that we link images essentially internal
images to sounds and
meaning effectively meaning
because
i'm here rapping to you right and i'm
making effectively small mouth noises
which are inherently meaningless
except that we happen to share a
language and so when i make these small
mouth noises
chances are your brain is reflecting it
in terms of
images i say chair you see a chair i say
star you see a star so i mean it's more
complex than that but i think that's the
basis of
cognition really and if you look at
culture if you look at it if you look at
consciousness it's all based on
this this relationship
between
sound
image and
and meaning or what they sometimes call
portentiousness
an ascribed meaning right it's a learned
association
that is not
automatic right i think about this a lot
with
say infants and language and
i i'm sure there's somebody to comment
on this much more intelligently than i
can but
when an infant let's say before they
develop full depth perception and so on
if they were to look at what's in front
of me they wouldn't see
laptop webcam
microphone
wood table etc
pile of papers as discrete objects until
they have
likely at least not to that level of
fidelity until they have labels for
those things right it might just be
a flattened
sort of two-dimensional sheet of
colors and shapes and shadows
and i think about that quite a bit also
as
you know you mentioned in the last
episode that you've
done
who knows how many sessions with
ayahuasca you know 500 plus and
it does seem that people develop or some
people develop an ability to discern and
see in those spaces in the same way that
an infinite sort of develops the ability
to
to discern between these kind of
discrete things that we have labels for
as adults
you